we're going to be showing a lot of The
Legend of Zelda today starting right
here we're going to show you what you
can do and we're gonna introduce you to
this amazing world but we're gonna try
not to spoil anything so feel free to
tune in for as long as you like about
yesterday open your eyes open your eyes
wake up Linc
this is a very mysterious place out on
Amazon simply taking up butter this
carried on
I mean Astana
little nazuna I've talked about breaking
the convention to sell to us but link
does start by waking up keep that rooted
in the tradition Bentham I'm gonna do if
they engineered Ashoka hello mom
let me study fossil their this really is
a mysterious place I know very that is
Ashika slate take it it will help guide
you after your long slumber
I can't receive the introduction of a
very mysterious item in particular I
didn't much never know never that day my
mother came to my horse
so in the past series we've used Wars
and magic but this time around we
introduced technology I know a lot of
people are going to be so excited to see
how that plays out in this game because
that's such a a great new wrinkle to add
to the Zelda franchise she does own the
kanji there I'm a game that's got it
yeah and he's gonna start with by
opening the treasure box
these are clothing items that you can
wear big 'rememorable in this I think
was I'm pretty much naked beautiful I'm
bill you can actually play this nude too
if you want not quite my style
coconut stated an enemy in your second
part I'll get it
that would also make you very vulnerable
to enemies so you know they take a mojo
sauce or today I'm hoping fast about
this fat to show you the way
so we see here when the functionalities
of the sheikah sleigh is activating
that's on this pedestal and opening this
door here
so it starts pink
you're on the light our light that must
shine upon Hyrule once again now go
done many jungkook do right now I'm a
hot a bit there
well done the dummy so as you can see on
the screen it says jump now Lincoln jump
for the first time coming up and the
jump is for him to climb up the walls
now we see the subtitle on screen
perhaps this would be a good time for
our new miss had no new son to talk
about that a little bit
so in the previous titles we use
character names and height and names the
subtitles but this time around we wanted
to showcase the world and I think
especially from that the sweeping
panoramic shot right there we see how
much how much of a character the world
is how much of a presence the the world
is in this and I know hearing some of
the iterations of possibilities for for
the subtitle and you know I remember the
moment when I first heard breath of the
wild and it was just like oh that's it
that's the right one it just it felt so
right with this the in tune with with
the nature and and the sort of
expansiveness of this world
hi Kiyomi Danny small she's a know
yourself you know has made its appetite
or hurry that put it on
carry out they've any controversy hype
tonight I'm on it don't on their habit
okay Yamato know what together man
so linking climb the mountain or the
wall but just like you said you thought
here that your Nana you don't I don't
know gaze down by the gate so that is
the green you see the green gauge on the
Left that's the stamina gauge and you
can kind of see how much he can find by
that gauge
SiC kinda pull up you don't know when
you and then there's a lot of items
scattered all around the world and you
can take those you can pick those up and
then Nintendo we of course have to have
this we love our mushrooms this mushroom
is not gonna make a link any bigger so
as we can see Lincoln's push-off big
rocks down the hill you can use all
these little items and elements and
incorporate it into game play mm-hmm see
already Bill doing some gathering a lot
of climbing here and already there's
this sense of yeah you're just thrown
into this world and exploration right
off the bat tanking most of its master
on the map no she kissed me somebody's
calling you though
so here we get our first look at the map
this circular area here being the extent
of the e3 demo that we're showing this
is a high plateau in the center of
Hyrule we'll give you just a sneak peek
of how big that is but I think you'll
get to see a better look at the scale of
the world later on today I don't know
nothing inches data I know it needs to
be bought on let me know I got a baked
apple
lucky me oh there you hook a baked just
called it Jim
oh now who who is this gentleman mr.
onuma
you like to share with people and in the
first of the series I think you met a
guy like this he says this is the great
plateau and he describes it as the
birthplace of the kingdom of Hyrule
hideout Oklahoma pendulum cheek no money
no backstory
more Taklamakan secondly on the
conference so you can see the temple
that's very worn down as he says the
kingdom is in a state of decay so I
picked up a tree branch earlier
currently it's all I have for a weapon
but you can see very quickly the things
that I can do with a tree branch
it's given off put it up you know people
might pick what you don't know about
everything I think we've just seen the
window into bills play style my stomach
I picked up an axe and so I can also
swap my weapons out so I'll switch over
to the ax the ax is great because I can
chop down trees if I want to get to some
apples use all the resources right I can
even chop the logs that I've cut to get
firewood which I can later use to set a
campfire it's very nice it's amazing
convenient yeah I think honestly first
time I got my hands on the round I spent
the first 20 minutes like chopping down
trees and climbing trees that's that's
all I did
cute Australia and the pea mobile pretty
high I've always been a big fan of the
courthouse
100 bucks on their tab or
so these guys are actually hiding
everywhere in the world
Oh what do we have there no no myself it
looks like I've already come across the
master sword did you get it already did
you find it oh no there's no way I'm
gonna play something that important here
that would be the ultimate and breaking
with the Zelda conventions no I do need
a shield so I think I'm gonna run up
this way as you can see the the world is
open to me I can go any direction that I
want but I'm gonna run up here through
the grass I've had the sword so perhaps
I should cut some grass but nothing's
coming out come on not anymore they
think you my dummy is okay so I guess
you want to know how Lincoln you know
dispatch them with some presidents there
we go
it's it's not much of a shield but I've
got a pot lid oh he's taunting me oh no
I'm gonna need some help here in a bit
no in a short rope so I stole his spear
combine an antique remove the cookie on
their captive is important so for this
title the weapons that link have
actually will break as he used some
day--maybe you tomorrow at a Chicago up
there I'll book you but I know by myself
before afternoon dull don't see your
ticket I'm house Ted Zoe book your
ticket so I'm the cycle of this game is
that you get going to a battle with
enemies and you take their weapons and
if we can use them at their home so
perhaps we'll head down and check out
some of these ruins
ding Oh Peter oh yes you have got your
hearts getting a little lower so Papa
left our time for they eat about three
Thor let's see no ball
look the by circular so I'm gonna study
hard to the lovely I messed over here so
you can see that little heart icon and
then it shows that you can get on path
of the heart back so keep the heart of
the consignee rock there nicob oh no pop
it there hi so this one around you're
not gonna find any hearts in the grass
but you're gonna be eating these food
items and you can get your energy
stamina back up using that way to
replenish your health
there's I love I love that notion of
really having to take advantage of the
resources in the world
with also with grabbing the weapons we
were talking about I know you're getting
up those from enemies you're you're
finding them in certain places and then
using using the food as this resource to
keep to keep your health up it's also
really a lot of fun
so it's almost like a survival game
where you have to get all you collect
all these items so you can move on with
the game
so when you match when you get a perfect
timing the enemy slows down and it's
easier for you to attack the enemy looks
like I got a new pair of trousers which
I've been needing to pick up okay you
can see that there's quite a lot to look
around at and discover in the world
you're gonna run past those barrels
they're the model
now mr. Masson we don't have a good idea
of what's going on in Hyrule here but
everything seems to be in ruin what am I
on a tour
Arsenal Palermo and the suspense the
cumin red onion
God yummy yeah so you saw these guys in
the trailer they're partying
dude the gun does get all you know we've
got them all and their enemies but as
you can see these guys are not moving
anymore
mm-hmm no some are identical it's a
common okay captain honest man there
must be some sort of a time lapse
hmm
so I know a lot of people are gonna be
really excited about how you're dropped
into this world and there's you know
minimal backstory there's not there's
not a lot up front in this game other
than here you are what are you gonna do
what do you want to do where do you want
to go and then yet there's so many hints
in this environment about that because
something is greater has happened I
think people will be really interested
to see the story sort of unfold as they
play the game caiman asthmatic aha
do you own a blue tie steak dinner party
and I use a song called another disorder
Stan I'm more presentable Wakata good
Autonomous Region this guy I'm again
with the tan technique oh you don't
start like not chapter 7s
so I think what this title you'll be
able to learn these back stories like
you said that that you'll be able to
learn them little by little on your own
pace it's not that the game is telling
you but you can kind of explore to find
out on your own
mm-hmm this might also be a good time to
talk a little bit about the art style
and just the nature of the game itself
the if you if you look at link and the
world it's clearly deeply inspired by
Japanese animation Monogue in Kannada
those title not call me to Thor he won't
know any
so the snare I know zero that they you
Tony hasn't Optima to Vinnie
I know turn T show me what it's got
there so animation motoyama polygamy
thomasgillam or sorry Bonnie
Arnold soil second season monotony moon
unarmed escapes or hockey debacle Sarita
mean you are a guy who more moto Carson
are are no it - take them kids take
their hockey the water after the toy
animation of gijón iboga no gaming ham
we did so we've used this to like style
before in the previous title news but in
order for the players to see an item to
find an island it's actually easier to
to use the animation style where you
create something and then you shave off
the element so the items will be the
users will be able to identify the items
easier rather than adding on elements so
to the background animation takes on a
whole cup there are no wrong answer the
Dakota timid or not there or it through
net and or game of chess
I know sorry Rhonda so the scene here is
not that we wanted to create an
animation style game but we want it to
to use this art style and in magic to
the functions of this game mm-hmm
and you see here the time limit to on
the show floor yeah we were supposed to
disable that that was that was my
mistake we'll skip through a few things
it's an organic playthrough it's true to
the nature of the game the users will
expand tonight on the show Marcel and I
think people saw you know that actually
gives people at home a sense of how much
time people are gonna have here and
there's Reggie said nobody's gonna be
able to explore even just this small
area that we're selling here at e3 and
that's that this experience is gonna be
and I think people are really excited to
sort of man but in in going back and
talking about the art style the the
colors are very reminiscent of a type of
paint called gouache and gouache was
actually it's it's a material that is
used frequently in in animation but it's
also a material that's used in a style
of painting that is called ammonia or in
in English open-air painting where you
you go out into the environment and you
sit down in front of the the object that
you intend to paint and you paint it in
that real-world setting
you know as we started looking at you
know the art style and its its
similarities to gouache and and that
connection we also started to feel that
the music in the game also has a very
open air feeling tune isn't that correct
Timon Ankur open air do you Tamara keep
telling that to go so don't let's get
them off so what I didn't know was it's
a memo to myself I know the only person
identical
so because the the players will be able
to explore and do anything that they
want to we couldn't use the conventional
types of music where we know that where
the users would go and we can kind of
get the music more dynamic as the users
explore certain areas of the map so this
time around we kind of took a different
approach so as you can hear there's a
lot of environmental sounds that you
hear throughout the game and then we we
try to blend that music that sound into
the game as much as we can Kyle let me
date that either come up and then you
can hear it a little piano sounds of
piano throughout the game I think
and in the sounds of piano actually
matches this on nature element very well
stolen I mean you go Hatake Rihanna
and then the sounds of piano actually
I'm kind of strikes a chord in people's
emotions too so I think it works really
well
nah I'm not taking them all today
Nanako co2 co2 ve come atomic lose any
my personal piano yeah so when when
you're playing the game and when link
goes through something and then if that
piano sounds happens to come on it kind
of it makes you feel so emotional just
hearing that perfect match of the
movement and the music so the music is
our intention was to because of this
game it has 100 ways of playing it if
there is a hundred players playing it so
we kind of wanted to make that that very
unique experience for every player I
know longtime fans of the series that's
going to be one of the first things they
notice you know there's not the constant
theme music all we always present
everywhere you go and this this new take
on the sort of on the aural experience
is really it's really refreshing it's
true to the game and it is it does
resonate it feels really good play
define you dr. Watson in court a
Mahanagar it ad on the background I got
a theory on a console online of them and
everybody home right now
Oh visioning process look at me now
don't nobody knows that they or me
Anthony only good cookery on the only
back scoop gonna put aside any updated
oh yeah I'm really happy to hear that
bill continuing there we go campaign of
brutality any other day so we do have
you know one of the things that we're
not showing in this morning segment
that's going to be coming up in just a
little bit is puzzle solving you'll be
seeing some of that today you'll be
seeing quite a bit of exploration and
the ways to use the objects that you've
discovered but one of the things you
know there's a lot of different ways
that you can kind of experiment with the
the environment in the world here in
breadth of the wild so I'm just going to
have a little bit of fun with a little
little project I wanted to try out here
and a segment and another topi that
study you know they're not and hooking
them up and Canadian or thank you not
Gamache mask it off to conquer buger
yadi totemic shooter step okay well I
like that you call this set of a project
bill that's see I don't know what you're
trying to do here bill
nope Oh get another club let's see
oh no not quite that was quite quite
dangerous thank you for joining us we
have a little bit of news I think
everybody has been excited for some
special Zelda items coming to me Toma
money and I better see that item I told
you that we've we've just been told that
those items will be going live at 3 p.m.
Pacific time so be sure to check into
miitomo today to get your free Zelda
themed items there we have a lot more
Zelda coming up to Velva as we as we've
talked about we're really focusing on
introducing you to the world the things
you can do in the world how you're going
to be surviving it's really all about
the actions and the activities you won't
be seeing so much in terms of characters
and story so if you're the type of
person who doesn't want to be spoiled
feel free to tune in all day yeah you
know it on a pedestal story so you need
focus tomorrow you're not there I hold
on oh I know you're saying focuses
that's he has it I don't know that's not
good on you not to go that's right I'm
gonna stay back stay back with me your
score guys there's so much more I want
to tell you about this game so please
look forward to it
yes so stay tuned we're gonna take
another look at our next segment we're
gonna be focusing on some exploration so
thank you Noriko mr. AI Numa thank you
Bill thank you very much for your time
and don't go anywhere we got more Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild coming up